in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Justin
and Katie are with us hey guys how are
you
okay great Dave welcome welcome good to
have you so you're you guys are from
where Dayton Ohio
Dayton Ohio well welcome to Nashville
and here to do your debt-free scream yes
sir I love it how much have you paid off
we paid off just over thirty two
thousand dollars good for you
and how long did that take it took us 15
months very good and your income
household range of income during that
time started out just over 80,000 and
ended up just over 100 good for you and
what do you guys do for a living
I am network engineer okay I am a yoga
teacher awesome very cool fun fun good
to have you guys well this is fun what
kind of debt was the thirty two thousand
it was the car and three credit cards
okay what happened 15 months ago that
made you guys decide that you were gonna
be weird and get out of debt so back in
2013 I was on a deployment with my
National Guard unit mm-hm and had a
buddy who was going through your plan
mm-hmm and I thought that sounds great
but I don't need a plan like that I'll
just pay off the debt so while I was
gone I paid off a truck and a credit
card no I'm good and got back we went to
Disney on credit and nine months later
we had run up right back where we were
yeah and so bought a car yeah yeah so we
had another car to health and so
basically I I was like this stress is
too much and I got your book
my dad had your book read that and then
I had to come to Katie and and try to
talk her into getting rid of this debt
which was very hard mm-hmm but I did
that and apologized to her really for
failure and leading financially in our
life because we had just been living
spending more than we made for a long
time and what did that sound like when
he comes in and starts talking about
that how much did your shields go up or
your your warning bells go off or what
no I thought it was a great idea when he
came to me I wasn't always aware of
everything financially so it was nice to
kind of come together and be kind of a
team and do that together so so to sort
of be in the loop made it all good
yeah and have a say in the decisions
exactly that kind of stuff that added to
the equation how to do the appeal of it
I guess yes okay very cool so what one
debt did you all pay it off and you went
I hate you people I'm so glad you're
gone for me it was the credit cards
because the funny thing is the 15 months
we thought it was 14 months I had paid
it we had paid it off
the boys pushed the buttons on on the
phone and we thought we paid it off and
then Katie called me a month month later
and said she had gone to the bank take
some money out and they said we owe $2
26 on our credit card they had a charge
interest I didn't even know they could
do that with a zero balance but I guess
they get you one last time baby yeah
it's my last buck 26 you ever get out of
me closing his account you get them all
closed up and don't have to worry about
that ever again wow that's fun so how
does it feel now different than it felt
say two years ago because now you don't
have any debt and now you're working
together back then you had that and
really Katie didn't him half know what
was going on at that time is that right
pretty much yeah so how's it what's the
difference feel like now versus then
from go ahead for me it just feels a
lighter load you know I he is less
stress and it you can tell when we are
on trips and we go places and we're able
to sort of have fun in a way that isn't
stressful mmm the way it used to be okay
for me it was its total its freedom its
the finance of free and emotional
freedom the spiritual freedom is just a
lot of changes fell off when that
happened so very cool so the boys
watched this happen
oh yeah I know what's going on yeah
they've heard a lot of your podcasts I
love it all right it's other names and
ages this is Lincoln and he's 10 and
this is Barrett and he's 8 all right
very cool and have they been practicing
all the way from Dayton they know what a
debt free scream is yes they do because
we kind of rate kids on their ability to
do debt free screams around here the
YouTube channel will jump in they'll
tell you about it if you kind of mail it
in so you got to go for it guys okay I'm
kidding no pressure no pressure we also
got a copy of Chris Hogan's number one
best-selling book retire inspired which
is the next thing for you to do is to
build wealth and
increase your generosity and go crazy
and of course it's signed by Chris and
everything so we'll give you a copy of
that when you're done and
congratulations very proud of y'all
thank you very much those are heroes you
took control of your lives it's amazing
it's good stuff so few people do that
that it makes you weird so you're not
normal anymore from now on it's official
all right Justin and Katie Lincoln and
Barrett Dayton Ohio $32,000 paid off in
15 months that includes a buck 26 and
they did that making 80 to 100 count it
down let's hear a debt free scream good
job guys
well done love it love it love it that's
the sound of a family tree being changed
right there dad and mom decided they
were gonna take control of their lives
as a boys watch it'll never be the same
it'll never be the same I remember I was
probably probably Barrett's age maybe
eight years old something like that and
I was at my grandpa's house and we were
taking apart an old shed and it was that
old school solid freakin oak that you
can't even drive a nail through it's so
hard the wood was and they had drilled
holes to be able to drive the nails
through the hog drilled holes is only
the other stuff in so we're taking the
thing apartness this stuff's like
concrete it's unbelievable and I pulled
a nail out and I began pulling nails out
of the boards because he was going to
save the boards of course and I started
throwing the nails away and he's like oh
no no no no you get those back out and a
lot of you had a grand ball like this to
God like I did and I had to straighten
the nail out I lay it on the board and
beat on it straighten it out get it as
straight as I could get it and then we
put it back in a can and we had those
old bent nails and this can which
wouldn't drive in anything it was
probably completely wasted exercise but
but that's how he was you know why your
grandma did that while your grandma can
tomatoes our whole life why your grandpa
pulled nails out and straighten them and
cap them why they fixed everything until
it couldn't be fixed anymore and wrung
every piece
of life out of every household appliance
you know why because they had an event
in their life in their childhood or
their young adulthood that's the same
thing that Lincoln and Barrett had an
event in their life their parents
changed the way they were handling money
now in the case of my grandpa and some
of your grandpa's our grandmas it was
the event was called the Great
Depression wasn't it it was the virtual
collapse of our economy combined with
one of the worst droughts which created
a Dust Bowl agriculture went and tanked
as well during that same time and people
didn't have anything and they had to
make do and that generation was forever
changed you could say scarred if you
want to the point that they never looked
at money the same way again they never
looked at money they never looked at
security from money the same way again
they never took anything for granted
when it came to getting value out of a
dollar and see that's exactly what
happens in your house when you decide as
for me in my house we're going to serve
the Lord as for me in my house we're
going to handle money biblically which
involves being on a plan and being
generous and getting out of debt so that
we can do more of both and we're going
to change our family tree and when you
do that the the changes that occur
inside of your heart in your behaviors
and your attitudes and your habits in
your relationship with your spouse the
changes that are required of you in
order to get out of debt will
permanently change your children because
they can't help but watch and go my
dad's a different guy
my mom's a different guy and we laugh
about around here and go you know they
were scarred by Dave Ramsey they were
scarred by the Dave Ramsey show they
were scarred by Financial Peace
University they weren't scarred they
were scarred by their stupid decisions
prior to that and they were motivated
and inspired to change their lives from
that point forward and never go back can
see so what happens is for these
debt-free screams you're not just
hearing the sound of one couple getting
out of that you're hearing the sound of
kids being involved and that means those
kids watch those parents change as
individuals and that's how you change
your family tree we're talking legacy
here big time legacy so when are you
gonna start your change yeah you talking
to you hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or twenty
seven thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar economy
you